no uh 50 billion sounds like a lot but
put it into context for us what is it as
a percentage of Berkshire's total assets
yeah it's it's really just about 10% of
Berkshire's assets which is which is
actually down from a decade ago because
what what warren buffett has been doing
is he's been buying these he's been
buying railroad he's been buying
electric utilities and that's really
expanded the size of the balance sheet
but it's also expanded the earnings
power of Berkshire so what you're seeing
is every quarter Berkshire Hathaway is
just generating a lot of money and
Buffett as we all know sort of waits for
the fat pitch he wants a really good
investment when he's gonna buy a company
when he's gonna invest in a stock he
wants to make sure he's getting in at a
good price so what we've seen recently
is that cash number really just climbing
at his company it was at about 55
billion which is an all-time high on the
absolute basis at the end of June now
during the last and after the financial
last financial crisis Buffett saw a lot
of fat pitches as you put it he invested
in Goldman Sachs and Bank of America and
Dow Chemical so what does he be saying
in terms of the prospect for another
correction what does he say about stock
market valuations because given that
we're at record highs he wants to see
things coming down a little bit more
doesn't it right it's it's actually the
funny thing so so we got these numbers
late on Friday Berkshire reported
earnings but for Berkshire that's just a
press release and they're 10-q filing we
get a lot of data but we don't get
commentary Buffett so really were just
left to speculate about what he's
thinking about right now
what is his skill set of saying no to a
deal my guys no one's told me that the
most important thing for CEOs to say no
how does warren buffett say no to a
potential transaction I think he does it
with sort of the grace and humor that he
clearly clearly he has no problem saying
no because so many people are trying to
get him interested in investments and we
know just the free from the frequency of
them that he's not biting that off then
Mary Ann do you see any fat pitches out
there well we don't get the company
specific but we do look at the M&A cycle
and we're very bullish on the
a cycle it's picked up the number of
deals is very high but when you look at
the dollar volume we're still way below
2007 what's really positive about this
means that corporate America has
confidence in order to do the deals is
the confidence there in retail Howard
Davidowitz no there didn't know it isn't
there's not going to be a consolidation
well there is a consolidation it's a
scary thing because people can't compete
we have tremendous number of
bankruptcies closed doors malls and
everything else
retailing is not strong as the
consumerism strong mr. Buffett started
was a furniture store in Omaha right our
investments right Danny hates retail
it's two percent of the business he
hates it and he says it's troubled ok
unquote